so i before
has
island mountains
a wewelsburg short point
receives both series the wgs born was
a big disappointment of course but
they were also caught i was
caught a detective noticed it and
that wasn't so bad anymore
he called my parents  on the
phone and so on and it
was a bit embarrassing
but when i had to give it back of
course this dictionary and then
the really criminal side came out
because i couldn't get over it
because i thought i
hadn't understood that
yet  it's not enough to have a dictionary
so after three days i went
back to the same i buy home
and this time i paid more
attention
i had to be the detective with
he looks that's
gotten again a playoff participation gdr directorate
wasn't the game
His criminal nature is the
3D content out that on Saturday it was clear where
preserved edition  were for which one
can go well apart from the course of events
but the disappointment followed immediately yes of
course I will drive there is this saying
suffering from distress is the case in this
case and that is because you need this word because
you i didn't know what
grammar is you need namely  not
only the words but also need the
grammar and you even need the
pronunciation isn't in the dictionary either
i mean for example with the danish
i can in which i can read everything even
without a dictionary can read almost without a dictionary
but i don't understand what the danes
say  it has something to do with the phonetics
it's unfortunately not that simple
otherwise we could all put many more
languages ​​a little liliput dictionary
done because without hans magnus koffer the possibility
to give your customers in europe the
possibility of their flap gram one counter
by counter from
the  Ms. told grab more and more
readers potency
nevertheless close this it with the
with the sentence one should  e be thankful for the tower of
babel
yes that will always be a
fateful thing out of high spirits a punishment from
god but i don’t agree with that at all
because there are
a few thousand languages ​​they say
there are 506,000 languages ​​in the world
but it’s interesting in  every
language can do something that the
others didn't know and that's why
it's a great asset
we can say at first sight I
can and even if you
speak Italian then you even
do things that you wouldn't do otherwise I
don't open my wine  German
stages in front of the the 56 and skoda films
for the part of the program keating
how many languages ​​do you speak yourself only
the neighborhood and they are only
from the neighborhood italian yes
just the ones in the neighborhood norway
on the other hand is not neighborhood for
you or yes it is europe  stop it but
but i can not my
polish would be a shame a neighbor
polish neighbors  can't i be
modest i really have our
monday be complaining and tell the audience
about
it in another book you tell
about your time when you were 15 16
years old when you were
in the hitler youth that wasn't a
big success and then you got into
the  books actually saved or yes
that's a bit of a funny
story
i hesitate to tell it because it
sounds like you were
a wonderful anti-
fascist even as a child but that's not true at all
i had what was possible i just didn't feel like it
the reason  Why I was kicked out of the
Hitler Youth
is not an ideological one but it
was just more that was uncomfortable because
someone was always shouting someone
always sent you around you should do things
why should I do that
I didn’t understand
and that’s why I skipped it myself  I
didn't go and then, as a punishment
, I was thrown out
ur dealer hitler youth
men system wait
christiane for the calculations about it
have dirk be very satisfied level the most
impossible vinyl french at the entrance
to the rennt ideological rally squared
dealer weiwei was in august 1 mainz
confirmed counters
but then instead of going to the café
they are like the city library well then
Of course you are what do you do then
because I do
n't want to be punished
by a policeman or something like that by a policeman or something like
that, what are you doing back
then in the dictatorship when I was a
very stupid person with these ugly
uniforms  walked around but not on
duty
why so i had to find a place of refuge
an asylum and i discovered one
there was a fine little library
in town actually not many
people were around it was such a
secret little library and
i could go there every week
and read books and there was
an old librarian he has
winked a bit a bit
otherwise got it he
already knew he already understood but you'll just
gave me all the books
I was allowed to for example also wonderful
all is everything you read as a child it's
chaotic you don't read according to a
canon reads everything  messed up africa
expeditions crime picture books with
naked women for example very
interesting things like
that gave me everything was a wonderful
musician also things that were actually
infected yes of course he had
has has for example thomas mann had
carinthia still had a level for interview
konrad buck hitler youth uniform  piste
was a good feeling because the leed
geschitt librarian etr librarian
there was still a seller in the magnus
the procedure qvc lohne ltd a
duisburg family driving ban are
so what you heard the 1 1 well stick with
my way the more if the service pack 1
and reader lisa  Fitz if we
now have a library you have
you a huge if we now
the war was over you have in
the last few weeks months you
should also be in front of electricity and
then you have certainly ridiculous
immediately my everyone who was not completely
blind understood that it was completely
pointless
they were not in the mood  with the
bazooka about playing the hero so badly
and then they met the
americans and were immediately used as
translators the small
word book dictionary may have helped
but i had an
english teacher the building was quite good as i
could communicate well in english
and when the
americans came english
that was of course wonderful
they shot at us first because the world was shooting at us during
the war
but i don't think they took it
amiss at all because
i understood why
they shoot you still don't have to hit the target
you had to be in the forest where you can't
pass and after  go home and
throw away the uniform
and then it was nice to rest and then
the position as a
semi-official translator for the soul
warm damm somehow in his
small town where the people didn't speak
english so i was suddenly
important because i was this
commander who had to  negotiate
and suddenly you had somehow
you could influence something a bit
although funny saturday new kriens lu 3
you can get into the embankment for the
handball fans qatar cousins ​​of the dax
components of the enns mccanns came in
serbia would have negotiations
hans magnus enzensberger ccr help with
a psychiatrist
feel free to come along we have the systems get
treatable hot dogs and copies
from your photographers and then you
also experienced what american
literature is one of the
wonderful things that was a
different america from roosevelt's
america was new deal there  were many
many of the soldiers was  en immigrants
who came back in uniform, for example, in
one of these companies, there was
an American professor from Berlin
, he came, he was Jewish
, and he went to America in good time and he
came back, and of course they were
great people, that was interesting,
I have the wife  they forget but i
play the story differently
that
you learn the bookcases from an american officer that
was part of this american policy
that was enlightened here at the time the
hard for the troops for the millions
of soldiers they had their own books
printed they were distributed free of charge  so
for the troupe you could in english
such paperbacks were distributed there
so that these poor boys
learn something together with young men there
and there was this big
box but the troop you weren't so
enthusiastic they didn't really want to
do what you're up to now
They didn't really want to read English or Kafka
the box was lying there and
then he said parts kempen take what
you want then i had the
books
and i read kafka in english first
because it wasn't in
german the american disruptor the politics
is followed the grazie borussia romanians
had  just as zitzelsberger as he was
testifies to that
for the fall she is then her store
cheese applicant to mr murphy core of the
state foundation begins nuclear power plant went
to the left points and messis
so bigger
then you studied and have
philosophy and literature yes but and
now the word is over very quickly
now the story is getting a bit
boring so let's move on quickly up to
now there will be quite nice stories
that just wasn't that nice but
no but the biographies of
writers are actually quite
boring these are people who spend
their time with it  to
read or write anything and it's
actually not very fun  nd
that's why they're all the same
but always the same and
that's why you shouldn't overestimate these biographies of
12 10 and 1 1 someone
i don't know someone who with the
fabia felix what's the name of the famous one there
the hanson yes yes yes that's one
interesting story he has a
biography but writing
doesn't have a proper biography the whole
boredom
you have to get your half will barcoo the
sixth gold what works is the juka 441
markus enzensberger for the entire water supply
but what i find interesting is
the history in
post-war germany  something that something like that
has meanwhile become a myth
, namely the group simon fach yes yes
yes but that's also a thing because
the literature historians and
literary
scholars of course love such directions ism
groups so that it's that it's so
practical it's a  data all in
one box that you can put in a
box that you can  meets him in
a box
the socialists are a box yes
the data are a different
expressionists there are 1000 boxes
and with these boxes you are of
course informed at the university
about the box
what is in the box that's what you do
box well I mean yes that was it  quite
nice
this group 47 was quite nice but there were a
couple of really good authors there were also
a couple of bad authors like it
always is with one in the box there are
different ones not always just the best
in the saddle and so on one has become
attached to one  year and it was everything
you can say and vegetables because in this
ruined country it was very boring
and it was full of old nazis and so
on and that's why you were happy that
at some point you were in an inn twice a year
and there were somehow  colleagues and
we agreed that things have to
be different here in this country that
was the common basis but
beyond that or d  apart from that we
were very different so if so of
course around that the list of
authors looks at our one very one
a very negative platform there was
no common aesthetics there was no
how but to write that everyone
did what they
wanted as a group  was that in this
formal sense it wasn't a group at all
it was just people who didn't
feel like fighting with this
stupid old nazis they
didn't want to they didn't want to they didn't feel like it they
were all still there you understand
they were yes  didn't
die you all because you with your they took
away your hitler pictures so
your hymns you wrote on
twitter you wouldn't hear them anymore you
didn't want to have anything to do with them
it was actually all about fibers
before the  next matches admits
states half christina deep a
bit out selena son otis
you may go by hand
siegfried lenz se  ine an der peter knows
how would you like to see an island of the
indie band as part of which, by the way, it has just
passed
with a lot of effort it then applies to you in the silo ligna the world has had a
lot of platforms since the q cells with
various things to ski off it goes with you
argued about the defense or yes, of
course, but then there was of
course that the warden was
somehow successful because there was a
we had made a little noise
and then it was successful and to the
extent that things changed,
the publishers listened  what where it
the a writer we we can
publish and so on and so it
has also turned a bit into a
mafia yes a small mafia
a modest no mafia
you knew each other you could you helped each other
you could for example radio
was moral  important back then you could do what the
consumer had broadcast time
you could do it
and so it was a bit of a
product for him  tion cooperative
everything can perhaps be said
that in the coface of a
powerful cache for the
canteen together these mafia kukident ames
result from it against trainer in which
the great father combi radium and
mental work defective the media are among the
ones that ultimately include a template presented
work depressing  but follow the
usa at mama mia and wrap sardinia
certainly no
damage of course as before the
total deficit forces in the current country
of steves forces so warwick davis degree
opens in wings as well as the board
earth natural phenomenon the holter soul
together
they then have their first  they didn't
publish a volume and then they
immediately started taking an interest in
european or
international poetry
and published the museum of modern
poetry 1960 a museum of
modern poetry the lid was already closed
or well that's classical
modernism what you mean  so called today  i do
think that it ended with the second
world war and since then something
else has been that that is no
longer pioneer can pioneering work more
so of in the sense of the mother
classical modern these people
were yes that was that i can
maybe you could also
say the heroic modern age, i.e. the ones with the
pathos of the wild
expressionists and they really have
something they have that was powerful that was
full of energy
but if something is called neo magath that
’s a tired thing have to take
that in  returnee was a
collection point modern thick the project
update first let on was screens fixed
one tells museum of modern poetry
she would have someone the classic modern
java therefore we turn to the role of
the poet and the guessing in
society to have written very very
much also in  these are also in
this the spanish narrow de
mission edition talks are for example
about talking z  for example from the hate
producers country where they talk about how
much the european tourism and
nationalism would not be possible without the military
support of the literati
just often acts as if
the culture the cultural life is somehow
something nobler something nobler rest that is
not  like this everyday art that is
somehow higher, so spiritually so
significant and so on and it is of
course also a funny idea
because of course these
philosophers these writers poets
these artists know exactly how the
other people do not know this any
better and just like it among the
other people, of course, there are agitators
and
fanatics and crazy
altar among the poets is the same the
proportion is pretty similar and if
you look in the twentieth century
even important authors were politically
completely kicked away turn away that
you say half crazy today
you can i  mine recognizes that you  there are whole stories,
everyone, every country, knows a
really such he
we find the cases and travelers of
stalin who the sympathizers of
hitler have one of their arms sonja and
sellin and so on you can make long
lists of those who were not
politically responsible for the
army  essay collection about the since he in
longer it at the help producer mountain
tells in european minister let
rent reductions
because the three without disturbing fixed
value land haft his politics
that you
have that already in europe as well as in the track
harder political fousseray
when it comes to fast way  he also threw them
so that all a national national
the songs they also have something like that the
terrible national anthem next to yes of
course it was marcel they say they
have to wait in the blood it says in the
mass of the official french
national she has that good so it was
n't  a bad
poem was also very nice, or our own
king left that he liked  e fit the
experimenta lust football is crazy
but it's like that, as you
say, literature or the literati
are nothing noble and they are just
policemen politically unreliable like the
rest that's why we
don't need them at all need church prophets do
n't use them at all  no prophets so
the prophet of the fatherland nobody needs
that should go home the prophet
of the fatherland we don't need to
lend that calculate the profit
we have the retailer then
we come to that practically now to the
60s where the big awakening was
there  you were already an old man
you were around 40 at the time, just 45 but
you were still there
somehow or I was interested in
something yes something interested you well
because it was the
post-war period when the 50s were, for
example  but an atmosphere that
was quite unsanitary that was there
were all sorts of fixes  n
obsessions there were still the
police, for example, there was still a
powerful let's show respect to
a uniform based on that there was in
germany that was almost wilhelm him
is that was very old and
i don't even want to talk about the seats
anything goes  possible forbidden for example
homosexuality was forbidden
loud that such things and it was
just a bit unbearable because
you have to do something and because
the whole the whole energy the whole
electrical charge in this very
generation that was then
expressed in the music yes that was  yes, in this
matter it was with the music, for example
today you no longer understand
what was so electric about it but that was
really great that was interesting and of
course like all political
movements political movements are
not
free there are always theirs  there are
also those who are terrorism and as far as possible
crazy, but that only means the
political movement  they are never free
somehow you pay for example
yourself the only successful movement
of the twentieth century namely the
women's movement think you will be the
only successful one also has victims there
the radical feminists were
n't allowed to have men for example that was
forbidden
it's uncomfortable that it costs  costs
what being forced
that was the other one who of course was
saying yes of course you can say
what do you want with this field
dimaggio away with your husbands there was a
part that then that was they
paid for it
and so someone always has to pay  rosberg
was
that goes all over the world deserved but
political stability like you get from us
is three authors took police officers
puffer the delivery ready
the idea successful in plus the service
tedious does it come from or is there
also critical little helper in geneva
reported ferenczy thing a
political movement
since the experience that ge denote
tricks  before the imster move 17h
detention piece they namely no movement
is the outside and the more than ten briggs
namely the mcafee ministers
gathered his building for the idea was the
other radical feminist
lost in five of the total a
sign of life of course I now
give all these veterans things  now there
are these old 1968ers they say to
these veterans who are
now retiring and then they talk so
touched how nice that how great everything
was next we were young and
beautiful in mainz that's quite nice but i hate
veterans like that  conversation
that's terrible so the money
comes from the iss in the eu the
resistive battery from
- the gruga with the famine backdrop
belongs to hans magnus enzensberger victory ago
the staff sgt 68 they were first in the
usa and then they left the usa
you artists too and went to cuba
you can hear your disappointment about the
utopia you thought cuba was 68 at the time
and see  n in your poem technology
sinking laser technology coming to the iceberg
on cuba
this is reading there are more
concealing can see different things
in it and it's not up to me
to decide how to read
it now it's a parable about the cold
war to  example why cold the cold
war is also that was also ours you
can make a personal story out of it
make a love story out of it
make a political story out of
it
it was in a way i come from a
political culture of the left and
i was in it i was very
interested in it i am  traveled to all these
so-called socialist countries
i was in the soviet union a lot
i was in bulgaria i don't know i don't know about
all poles and so on -
looked at everything
no i just think what i see
books is not enough it's not enough the
books you have to see there you have to  and from time
to time it was over i
understood that nothing will
happen it won't  cht that's not going to
happen with the soviet thing that was very clear
to me and then i thought well
then we'll go somewhere
else let's see how it is because in cuba
were not like the tanks
the these  revolution
but should the cubans themselves, above
all, mostly the majority wanted to
change
that, they made this attempt and
then i thought i'll take a closer
look now i have to
see for myself i was in cuba for nine months and
had to realize that  that's exactly the
same mechanism as in the
other socialist countries smoke
when saying goodbye you have to say
goodbye to
it you can't just because it
suits you like it maybe you ca
n't do that it didn't make
sense the crowd
when a baby listened  the kuwait open
socialist countries are doing the thickest
facebook because of
this being the 1 trade law faster in this center
he travel euro
this thinks of the socialist
russia was he soviet union started
were right times type cody added but
clearly the top 10
when summer from daegu was for the
then every water therefore games
fund of the killer socialist said so
closes is bothering if you
mother government  is the cd mistress led
hermesdorf to be empty
his cdu pendant aquaro ezb was
a big one but on the other hand i'm
surprised there were many other people
coming to cuba in the second year in that period or always soviet union albania
china came back enthusiastically and said
great we want  they were also in the
shrouds of the delegations in their hotels,
these old trotskyists, these
french trotskyists, of
course, they were incredibly flattered because
the big boss received them,
the comandante and so on, and they were
invited,
now they thought
it was great, but they did  haven't seen anything
we already wanted to have a good
mixed p  ults went and it's not
worth it
why should that be surprised i
don't understand that the rifle holds patents in series at hamm
so bring the current
right to vote in my application to eystruper
china
so there comes he was the
enthusiasm as a cold later
horrible whole was vince  gaffney
europaticker show party so regulated
these the beer bar and what several places
for glos commander of islam is also
so regulated with a gentle slowly
i maybe also had the
hall advantage that i couldn't
remember i could remember our
own dictatorship our own
propaganda the speech line riesenstahl films
this whole this whole staging and
and
i saw that a little bit differently as a child
and yes it's not bad and
just a bit of skepticism is
useful just useful a counter in front of
that is skepticism  on the kitzinger in
the incident responsible to us well
the citizens noble  are the shores to be
rehearsed where the visitors surf the be
before their protests now
let's talk shortly before the sinking of the
titanic that it was a huge success
not only in germany but also
internationally against denmark a
wonderful success
they called it the sinking of the titanic
a  comedy
and why was the addition necessary is of
course a literary
allusion to the divina commedia
that's why I played it like it
is a bit of a gimmick there
are 33 songs
just like dante and so on and
but that's actually the reason for something
else  because i think we are
actually not tragic so our
civilization is speak now of
our countries that denmark is
or
compared to other human
existences also in history
we starve to death for example
no one anymore it if if if if
someone knocks on the door then  do
n't you think right away that i'm the
gestapo i.e. d  that means we don't live in the
total seriousness of history and it
means we are we also have
our problems and i would see that under
the term
tragic comedy we are tragically comic figures of the
civic association since then with the
grade 1 or even prisoners in pollenca because that
audience the hr number of his dsl volley
tragic the office from there
neermoor european shooters or thinking
about carrying
our little tragedies yes these
famous things a good 1000 films are
about it that's
bad if a coffee
breaks it's not pleasant but it
's not that  end of the world
it's a sauna for that it's
uncomfortable but you shouldn't
do it either and that's why it's boring i do
n't want to read novels about adultery i
'm not interested it's always the
same what's the point madame
bovary and anna karenina it was enough
for him  e book
also show how first departure airlines
aua is ok of the catering rakusa madame
bovary a small  rest little for
the pacific must be i will
wonder how much more to reveal we will pass on
immediately you write in this 1
this essay is about how you
are trying to get to know america
you are writing about seven different
attempts these have
and if i briefly about them  a few things
may be mentioned during the war what
for you was a utopia with indians and
criminals after the war years it was
wealth and literature as a student
you got a travel grant
and traveled to rome for six weeks
and you also saw
apartheid or the usa then came the
blockade of berlin and the so-called
cargo cult but it is that
suddenly everywhere the care packages came across the
border from the usa
and then 68 came the complete name
then came your name and then you have
the 80s that the magazine from
that i actually wanted  also
founded transatlantic what did you want
to achieve with it
oh that was a real mu  nter continues
with his yes as you there is this
wonderful old magazine the new
yorker it has a certain elegance and
i got the impression that
german journalism lacks the
art of reporting was a bit
underdeveloped
yes and it was forbidden it was the
botanical  because the Germans, of course,
with all their problems, are beating each other
in the chest, so it's
somehow the fault of the knowing and so on,
everything is a bit like that and I thought
that's enough, now we want to be a
little lively, a certain level of vivacity,
we want cartoons, we want
we want something funny in music that
isn't forbidden and so on and
then they made this attempt but
it wasn't a great success because we
were too gorbachev once
said life punishes you too late
and vice versa it's the same  if you come too early
, life punishes you and
we were just too early
that was the germans were still a
luxury  terribly forbidden that was the
mentality back then when we started to
act but you can't always
win
the swb of the matter with every child a
cell phone according to the department apropos understand
under the big project words without
war in plans remains utopia i
feel in that berlin gangster first
crisis without doing the rieder nature
you come to you ne was a trip 6 o'clock
trip to the usa scholarship holder of the corner
just around in the place but there it goes his
son divergence google blog air berlin
was there are parallel leones pity
like a goal  berlin termes detour of
tuesday collar well cleared that on
a sack of rice the usa traveled cooper 34
franzi the 104 is fundamental forces
transatlantic connexio merit of this
gorbachev be
the parties know the latter bring the
latvian league to a hurry
the three years seen something
digitas liebig und  then tell
me about it maybe tell me
now you also have america now
v  have risen so many have no it will
be very interesting because most
europeans love in the in the illusion
because they have hardly learned english they have
read english books american books i have seen a lot more to
true in new york than if that is
like as if  it would be similar
but in reality american is
actually a different civilization and
just because they speak one kind of english
doesn't mean that it
's that similar it's different and that's
always a new puzzle
you don't always understand just one part
of america you're surprised  every
time i look, for example, now
the reports from this sagna convention
where the presidents are the
candidate will i will think that is
exotic, like thailand is a foreign
civilization that you ca
n't imagine i mean you
can imagine that  a danish
wants wants prime minister has and he
makes such a show that you can see
don't imagine it's unthinkable and so
there are wonderful things from great
surprises
i mean i'll tell you now what i
mean
for an example an example of the
americans i know americans that
i glimpse i've
seen them three times in my life if you say yes me
I won't be there for the next three months if
you need an apartment in here is the
key
so the generosity the
helpfulness of the Americans is
something that we are compared to in
one of my apartments no
stranger comes such things like that they have
wonderful
wonderful things then  the
friendliness so no one help you and
even so saying all this and then
horror the absolute horror comes of
course that yes if you squat like that
pictures loneliness is loneliness is
friendship loneliness everything such ideas
mean something else in
america is a friend every man who makes
me a  christmas card send for
christmas yes that is my friend
jed  it's strange like facebook is actually
like facebook and the terrible
loneliness when you're in america on its
on its petrol station at 2 a.m.
with the greyhound bus there keeps us in
a desolation and its
loneliness like hoppers when the formal
tires are good here  the
americans say the best things about america
the americans themselves say the
zeil america western europe estimates of
the dementia content count corporations
saturday in the nvidia above when the
lcs criticism and thus carriers the park i
ninth is unfortunately this
trip is my westhofen america pastor  heinz
bielsa the story in simple 65 meter apps
games in the
picture after that you afforded yourself a huge luxury
and opened your own
library
you have become a publisher please
yes many many years long 22 years and
become more than 300 volumes in time
yes, but that was a strange
constellation because that's how it
usually is, that person decides  ge
so the chapter pays the capital if
we don't if i'm the owner of a
publishing house i can decide what
is printed there and that wouldn't be the case
and i had a great
contract i didn't have capital i didn't
have any shares but i had
boxes i  I was allowed to do what I wanted
and otherwise I wouldn't
have done it for 20 years that was great because
I didn't want
to write any red numbers I didn't want any
losses because red numbers are
independent are dependent if I
don't want too much if I just
loss was over so but
i didn't need a return i didn't need to
make a 5% 10% 15% profit
it's enough if you don't lose money
the company 4 is the reason for your life's work at the
limburg front the other library
with the gentlemen c single straw woman the
elimination  a capsule is alex coupe de
with a five-day told that
google called grow would be wonderful brought
rostock the bonus poo  l my lord bourgeois
inherited profit dance group so the
number was high
i looked up the lists yes
which authors pretty crazy it is
all mixed up and from all over the
world yes but i am no
longer a messy reader like i was as a
child i was also tidy  but what
bothered me
yes i looked up how many
danish authors the only thing that
interests us here yes and there is
a book by hans christian andersen yes
twice already the church comes to the church
exactly herr and then the
big surprise jens day and
that's it
yes the reporter exactly you are very
good as always only you have to see
that as not a relatively small
publisher most famous authors are in
steady hands they
are yes i mean i can't
now i can't i can't i
can  not so slippery or import something from
america because they all
have their publishers so i have to discover
something  cken and that was fun too
you could just do things whether the old or
completely indifferent whether the already
2000 years dead the first volume was
from an ancient
writer a satirist rest of
syria he has driven to war is called luki
lies lies narrators  satirist very
funny man and it was the first book
and the second word was a
brand new book that had never been printed
i didn't stick to the
rules and that was maybe that
was also a reason why it was
quite successful
because  if you always stick to the
rules there is it gets boring
then it's not a good idea either
the band your trainer as the festival winner the
film a foreman gammel so the free
models that jens berger to the end
customers
december so sir didn't fade
away  there three classes on a trip
over an organ classic institute would come
the quads one would like to
surprise oneself  and that means you
actually want to surprise the others
then it would all be so he
didn't want to get bored it's not that
out we know that no one else had
these values ​​at the meeting surfer
holzer from 1 they were talking
about the liar
you also wanted a poem about
always being a liar and that's
why the poet was a liar
that's so the strange thing is
that these chief zellers and especially the poets
always talk about poetry they
also don't just talk about apples
or glasses they talk a lot about
poetry  often and you ask yourself is
that the narcissistic are you so
sure of yourself are so important and so on and that's why i have certain doubts about the other so-called role
that was already mentioned the
role of the intellectual the role of the
writer
that  i often find it a little
uncomfortable because why not why
aren't there any congresses about the role
of the pastry chef in society a
world congress yes where one should get one's
head involved be politically active be
politically active before you read yes
that simply means more
reasons why the poets lie because the
moment in which that was
happy is never said to be the
happy moment  is because the
dying man cannot quench his thirst
because
the word working class
does not occur in the mouths of the working class because we despairingly
have no desire to say
I am a despairing because the word
orgasm is incompatible with orgasm
because the dying city to claim
I believe  now only a faint noise
makes it clear that we don't understand
because it's the lovers who are
in the ears of the dead with their
terrible news because the words come too
late or too early because it's someone
else who's always
talking and because he  of which there is talk
is silent
in the dictation that lies after d  em exit
of the group
but what is the
big difference for you, for example,
between writing novels and writing poetry
that is an old distinction but
for so improbable poetry is
older than prose because in the songs
the old songs are everything  better
than politicians than poetry around while the
persian is actually the primary and
the idea of ​​writing prose now
is a later idea good and
there is another difference which is
interesting to me because there is
in sport there is the 100 meter runner
there is athletics  the 400 meter
hurdles 400 meters there are 800 there are
2000 meters and in the smartphone and is
a temperament thing i marathon is
too long for me
it is very economical because it is a
bit difficult you
can write a whole book about the habit what the
habits why people  habit
what is you can write a philosophical
book that thick but with a
gedi  cht about the habit you can see on
one side that is very economical that
is for me that was at foursquare in brazil
are positive and magpie
great military command sener for
the sed euro more that we are
now on the pulse of the portal wikileaks without
fun with temperament economical  how to
win but we just have we have something
new with grandchildren of the mainstream lies
in the negotiation sprinter short
distances that is a
sprinter they have excelled
in all i think of the
aryan disciplines with
even oratorios or find
film screenplays and core group maybe
true as non-fiction says as we do
a funny expression for us too, as if
as if things are only stated in non-fiction books
the others are irrelevant or
what is not surprising always wondered
that you have also dealt with
mathematics something that humanist
poets normally
regard with disgust and
leave to their bookkeepers  n or your auditors but never
deal with
it yourself you can call it a hobby because
i'm not a professional mathematician
where does the fascination come from yes because it
's fantastic as you know it's
incredible when you
build a cathedral out of your thoughts
it goes on  one after the other
so the one mathematician
david one more tower he can
still go on and it apart from the
pragmatic side it is of course
much more interesting is it is
as mathematics as art a kind of work of
art number theory i mean this
idea is the prime numbers  something so
ingenious when you
can do that then your brain blossoms when
you deal with it it's
not as if everyone agrees people
always do it they go to
fitness studios and where is the fitness
for the brain always here
why not here on 12 the cancer risk
if you edit and get the
mails with first responders ju
nge prinz em-form new - princess farm teams
was a gymnastics qi the fitness of
coming out before the em-tournament cards with
normal training than in the year have to
be rather dull with wins trades and you
got them at the price of the german
mathematicians my article
for sonja waiting but i'm
quite innocent i wrote a
book that means the numbers devil
and i actually
only wrote it because i have daughters
i'm someone who prefers daughters
and she annoyed me about the
lessons at school  again
mathematics is made into a boring routine
thing and i was
annoyed we wrote a book
for my daughter so that she would have
these misconceptions and and
i was completely innocent i
really wrote that for my daughter
and then with it a single bestseller
1  Funds for the avatars received prizes
a seeing least sudden
green system and  list 11
you fall heavily into the game and some
dark potency are
coming we may now come to the
conclusion what the poets are writing for
is it now the the narrow
the poorest literature which also
includes poetry when they
describe the write about  write the function of
this literature
never mention the word that is otherwise often used
, namely elitist literature that
is definitely quite deliberate i think that
is
this is an imaginary figure for
i don’t have one i’m not a
market researcher so i when i make a
toothpaste  can i do market research
then i can ask the people
do they prefer a pink toothpaste
or a green one and then i will make the
appropriate toothpaste but
as a writer i can’t
proceed
like that at all i don’t even know what the goal is what
people want
i have no idea  you have to
try that and sometimes there
are no arguments at all  e
quantitative questions because there are books
by me as I said this year somehow
because two million
copies of this zahner devil has yes but there are
n't I also have books have
2000 copies for so for
Germany that's little here it would be for 2000 is
yes  better than nothing yes but
it counts as little it counts as little but they
have to be
i can't take it into
account that they might be particularly
interesting books yes
you don't know so all these
calculations interest you as a
publisher they are interesting but  for
a writer you are completely
uninteresting
the teeth have the smiley count
the higher dictator because you are on
a corner right now be on the
skinny there the the the imaginary reader
music and film boret read a user's
films the dealers are tells you
our tent  tent specimen poor
not collection but directly to this
crisis to initially unclear
matter z  related but this time I was
looking for so-called narrow literature,
which is then written for the happy few like you also write in one of
these ss
, who then also discover something like that,
you don’t know beforehand on television
, it’s a bit like when you make
a suggestion and then leave  you
wait again to see if someone is coming
sometimes someone is coming take that
you can't know in advance and it's a
good thing because otherwise we would be the whole
video like the bank we're not the
coalition then it would be pure speculation
that it doesn't work like that and you  do
n't know beforehand
i think it's good much better so the ignorance
also has something for itself
the evp the manchester
rpo that's another interested
person demands hessens berger thank you
for this interview
it was wonderful you got
through the time thank you very much